[Music]
times became hard because Hitler became
more powerful and it disturbed our
beautiful life we didn't know from one
day to the other what's going to happen
the family was very strong and it was
just unthinkable absolutely unthinkable
that somebody was some power would be
able to unroot us
[Music]
[Applause]
first of all we felt that if there's
going to be a war it's gonna be like a
blitzkrieg it's when the last maybe a
month or so and then it's gonna be over
so we felt well if it's only gonna last
for a little while the Jews will survive
they always somehow do we didn't think
it's gonna last long first of all number
two we didn't believe what he's what he
said or what what he's gonna do that
it's gonna really happen and one night
they marched by our window with torches
and singing as our songs and stopping at
the house of this relative of mine and
bringing him some sort of a solution and
I also remember how impressed I was that
somebody would get a whole torchlight
parade this is me as a 10 year old very
proud as a matter of fact to have this
uniform I believe at that time everybody
reaching a certain age had to join the
Hitler yoke the greetings were changed
from Salva to discipline and solver
magista it was changed to Heil Hitler
we had to he came in and he said heil
hitler students and we had to stand up
saying how hitler teacher and then we
had a different curriculum because we
had this awesome kwinda which is certain
racy ology that was a regular subject
that we had and we were supposed to
learn what an Aryan is the Aryan race
Center opposed to the Aryan race we were
the Jews and the children were to daily
students were to learn what makes the
difference between a blond blue-eyed
pure Aryan to a Jew and I hated this
biology teacher with a with a passion he
he always pulled me up on my sideburns
and he put me in front of the class and
I see now he has a jewel
and he started to describe my nose and
my cheekbones and my hair and my
features and how to recognize a Jew and
I was very humiliated and I hated it and
I was I felt terrible about the whole
thing all my friends that I was good
friends that I would never think that
they would do it they were singing
anti-semitic songs and they make up
their made-up songs and I recall one one
song they were singing it that says
remembered you you are polish soil you
bones we will pile on a heap hitless
calamity you will not avoid and we will
beat your [__] destiny with a whip
when we lived amongst these people
before 1939 we knew that they hated us
because in Poland there was nothing
hidden ever since I could remember as a
child going to school I would see on the
street be it on a fence or on a building
of a Jewish home or front of a Jewish
store or the sidewalk there were signs
you call it the Ruffini here today signs
all over the place you go to Palestine
you filthy Jew we don't want you in
Poland and of course the anti-semitism
in Poland was becoming more open because
Hitler was Germany's the Nazi Party had
a great influence of the Polish
nationalists body they had a priest he
published a newspaper his name was Sean
stetic father Chuck he published the
most anti-semitic newspapers if you
wanna be there's a joke is it ok but
there was joke was a Jewish man sitting
and Warsaw on the bench and he has this
anti-semitic paper and he's reading so
another friend that you passes by he
misses but Ryan was why did the sighted
persons are not to submit what are you
reading suspect that he's just slimy
if I eat read the Jewish papers all I
read about Soros the Jews
around here that this dad but they don't
in German I'm depressed so if I want to
feel good take the anti-semitic paper
and it says the Jews owned all the
apartments in home
the Jews owned all the factories they do
not the richest the controlled world
control America and
[Applause]
I remember the beginning of the war I
remember the speak Hitler I remember the
whole frenzy that all of a sudden the
rose up and where I was in the
environment that I was the people I knew
including my teachers was all for the
war and I think in conjunction with that
form whatever stood in its way to be
destroyed
I wasn't even unhappy about that I
thought of war I'm gonna be a hero and
tanks were rolling by day and night we
were sitting in the windows we were so
caught up by this display of might that
I thought my god I could so get I'm here
I remember the war coming to our town
with a very severe area
I remember the whole city was I just an
inferno and we all ran for our lives so
he crossed a river called visla and
certain things you can remember and one
of the things I remember as we were
crossing in a little boat we just looked
at a wall of fire and back of us and it
was bombing constant bombing and
everyone was going towards East
the roads were littered with trucks and
bodies bodies and bodies everywhere and
I was swept with the sight of people
going east I had no idea how to get home
I had no idea how my family feared and
everyone was trying to evacuate but
there was no way no way there was a
Polish girl in my dormitory who was very
good to me who helped me out a lot and I
figured out gee she's only a couple of
miles away from here I'll stop there and
I'll get something to wear to cover
myself I had a fluency nightgown now as
soon as I came down to her gate she said
get away from here you dirty Jew and
this is the first time that it hit me
that I really understood what it's all
about
we had refugees from Poland Polish Jews
who told us do something go go to the
end go to America go to Israel go to
Palestine do something escape because
that's what's going to happen to you in
return
that's impossible I mean my father was
born here his father was born here and I
my great-grandfather's
was born here it's impossible but we
didn't know enough had we known enough I
think we would have done more my mother
decided that she's gonna go over to a
friend of hers returns after the
adjournment she had to her friend
instead of a look here I don't know
what's going Kevin to us I've got here's
some money keep it for me keep it I
don't know what I'm gonna come back but
if the kids are going to come home give
it to him
give it to them if not keep it this very
friend of hers went to the authorities
and she turned in my mother's the real
fear was from denunciation suppose you
would try to hide the Jewish person in
our city it was not safe somebody who
didn't ask you
so this I hold up as a crime as a
collective crime our people were still
too anti-semitic and the dice the good
people at home the Jewish friends could
have counted where they were scared
the the most we the least prepared to
take on this huge brutal machinery which
exploded all around them we still
couldn't believe what the Germans had in
mind
total annihilation of our people it was
still beyond comprehension as a matter
of fact for the bulk of the 68 months
under the German occupation at no time
did I realize or believe that day this
was a total annihilation Frances going
on
[Music]
in the beginning they organized a ghetto
and they pushed all the people from the
small little towns they put stuff in and
about I don't know how many square
blocks and they built walls around a boy
so ghetto
you talked I don't know if you anybody
can feel this feeling you know with with
all the freedom we have today nobody can
feel this feeling of being trapped every
day there were different decrease Jews
training new bicycles Jews training your
valuables to string in your winter coats
children are not allowed to go to school
Jews don't work on sidewalks one day
they said they want 25 bookkeepers so of
course people who were bookkeepers
volunteered they were all shot on the
spot then came about the Edict of
hostages 10 Jewish men were named as
hostages and their names were posted on
placards all over town should anything
happen to a German those 10 men will be
executed they knew because of the
hostage system nothing would happen to
them this perhaps is also one of the
reasons why the majority of the people
in the free world cannot comprehend why
6 million people could allow themselves
to be led to the slaughter
like sheep without lifting your finger
in their defense it is very difficult to
raise a finger against the machine it is
also very difficult to live knowing that
because of my foolish act 10 men have
been executed and their widows and
orphans
[Music]
we would hear certain sounds of boobs on
the street and usually whenever there
was a transport it was accompanied by 10
to 12 soldiers coming marching together
from house to house in gathering all the
people knocking on the doors and saying
you you have an hour and we used to live
in each other of these foods and my
parents were back there and I had a deaf
sister so I became the yes I would have
to warn them doctor the transport was
coming we had this - we had noise
outside the house there were yelling the
Germans
and they they came to the door and had
burst into the room they kicked a dog
with bayonet experiment steel helmet
strap around the face of all
paraphernalia wall to listen and they
started to yell we should undress
so we all enticed mother woman amen
and then one of them said that my father
didn't undress quick enough and he
started to beat him on the face with the
burner talking and they started to took
out matches and I thought that they
gonna strike the matches no they took
out and they struck our genitals the
woman's in the men there were only a few
minutes in the room maybe telling it all
so frightening Germans
are the most enlightened educated people
in all of Europe at that time yet I saw
with my own eyes
Germans tossing babies in the air and
shooting them I couldn't believe it
but I saw it it did happen and they were
laughing as they were doing this you
know a lot of people don't know and they
feel that we weren't really very passive
but if you want to look at history and
I'm sure you know enough that countries
like France or Belgium or Holland they
went in a few days the Germans came and
took over once again I was holding out
for four weeks even Poland didn't hold
out for four weeks we were holding out
for four weeks the Germans were really
afraid to come into the war together
then they came in with tanks they
decided to liquidate the voice together
this was in 1940 clits
Passover and by that time well maybe
20,000 people left we didn't have much
ammunition so we told them a lot of
Molotov cocktails on the tanks and a lot
of Germans got killed you see my mother
was with me my border one day the
Germans came in this was a tube and of
the Warsaw Ghetto
I want you to know my mother wasn't even
40 years old neither was my father but
my mother was the Germans were coming
and we had to pull ourselves up on that
robe I told you in the building and she
couldn't make it so she went into the
bunker the law with the resistance
it wasn't exactly with several blankets
we didn't make big bunkers because we
didn't want it if the Germans will come
in we should have not only people should
be caught so we we had like five
different bunkers downstairs and we were
hiding upstairs maybe 50 60 people
upstairs my mother couldn't make the
walk because the Germans were coming
very rapidly and she was hiding
downstairs and after they left the
Germans I went to look for her and she
was gone everything was burning you
couldn't stay there they they smoked us
out people had to get out from the house
it's a good night and then not only on
top of this after the houses were
burning they came in and they demolished
them so even if you were hiding the
people got suffocated on the need they
came in a firetruck emit a ladder they
took us all down so it was my border
myself at that time I was made my
husband and his sisters we're all hiding
there maybe 50 people
some of the more effusive of so the
Germans killed him right there
so we piled up the dead people and we're
we're digging get the cemetery and
somebody brought a little girl to the
grace a Jewish girl she was maybe four
years old a blonde little girl the
parents gave her a way to polish people
to hide and the Germans gave an order
anybody's gonna hide is gonna be killed
so they brought the little girl in the
shunned arm was standing there on top of
a little hill and watching us work so he
went over to her and he gave her an
apple you need Esther what's this
in Polish so she named it yup car which
isn't polish awful in Esther name and he
repeated it broken broken polish a one
vector was post and he started to
lectures about the Jewish mother he says
this is kinda motor this is not the
mother who leaves a child and he said I
assure you that she's not gonna go for
that mother who run away and left his
child we're gonna get it and why the
girl was eating the Apple he should he
aimed at her and the bullet went through
her hair
and it screamed the child scream and he
shoot her again and killed her and the
child felt that to the ground and the
upper rows away you know we better check
with the rest of the others by 1943 my
parents realized it was just hopeless
that there was no point in trying to
live in this fearful way and so they
decided to send my sister and me to a
farm family out in the country for which
they paid great sums and I had to hide
the fact that I was Jewish at that time
I was nine years old I had my sister
with seven and a half and then the Sun
came back to the farm and announced to
me that my parents had failed to pay for
the last five months they never told us
that they had already been taken by the
last transport out of practice to the
man and I took my suitcase and my sister
looking for a place to stay and I would
go to places where I knew people who
were Christians
I knocked on the door and they slammed
the door right in my face and not saying
it would not explaining just it's a fire
we're just a beggar at the door and they
just closed the door in my face
and finally I went to their home these
friends of my parents were living on the
forged Passport and they did the same
thing and then I knew that indeed I was
the last to act it was nothing for me to
do for two days we were scrounging we
had no money we were scrounging around
trying to find food
and finally I said to my sister
we can't live that way but now I on the
street so we might as well just go to
the police and I went to the police and
I said my name and I said my parents
name and I said I'd like to join them
Amy finally we put on the train and I
was told that I would be going to
Auschwitz I saw they taking away the
men's separate the children separate and
their woman separate so I had had the
baby and I took the the codes for the
hair bundles and I wrapped around the
baby and I put it on my left side
because I saw the Germans were saying
left or right and I went through with
the baby but the baby was short of
breath started to choke choke and it
started to cry so the German called me
back this is what what do you have there
in German now I didn't know what to do
because everything was so fast and
everything happened so suddenly I wasn't
prepared for it to look bad the
experience was I think I was numb or
something happened to me I don't know
but it wasn't I wasn't there you and he
stretched out his arms I should hand him
over to the bundle and I hand him over
the bundle and this was the last time I
hid the bundle
and I call when they were piling us into
the car and they wanted everybody to
move back so they could put more people
in eventually people kept going back but
there was no more room I do recall them
they fired across to make more room so
shoved another batch of people in I
remember a good percentage of people
died for three days people defecated on
the floor three days we didn't have any
food or water and again I then I
remember that the thirst was the
overwhelming thing we just couldn't that
is again something that keeps recurring
in my mind this constant thirst and I
remember when they led us off the cattle
cars and book evolved there was a hose
with water and something couldn't make
it to the moon I sneaked up to the fence
and I found a hole there it was a raw
wood fence and that was the day when I
saw my train the potty train and it just
must have pulled into the station right
in front of me stood one of the wagons
and one man immediately jumped off my
feeling was my instinct or what I'm a
dad that he was asking for water and
immediately that as a soldier with the
club of his life clubbed him down and
several times I - in sensitivity better
he died or whether he was later put on
the track
and then I heard anyway I was so scared
and I was so upset I never saw anything
like this in my life I simply ran away
they are still here they don't um nobody
sent a word we were just wondering where
are they going to take us one morning I
think it was morning or early afternoon
I don't know we arrived and then the
train stopped there for an hour why we
don't know and a friend of mine said why
don't you stand up there was just a
little window it's bad let's see I said
I kid I don't have enough energy to
climb up she says I'm going to sit down
and I you stand on my shoulders and I
did and I look out and I saw paradise
the Sun was bright then maybe there was
cleanliness I know but it was a station
somewhere in Germany the first three or
four people there one woman was a child
nicely dressed our child was crying
people people the people not animals
and I thought paradise looking like this
and I had still feel it in my bones
I had such yearning to live to run to
just run away and never come back to run
to the end but there is no way back I
mean I told the girls I girls you have
no idea how beautiful the Sun is and I
saw a baby was crying and a woman was
kissing that baby is there such a thing
as love
but my brother died in my arms my
younger brother was
and my husband's two sisters it's not
enough oxygen for those people and they
kept us in touch bargains for days they
wanted us to die in the organs
you know the cattle cars with their
little windows you know my nerves
it said mice ain't gonna be I must be
the only one survivor for my family I
made up my mind I'm gonna defy you I'm
not gonna give it because he wants me to
die I'm gonna live and before they
arrived at Auschwitz maybe it's new - we
were in Auschwitz alright if we didn't
know where we were
I never heard of our sheets which are so
people running around like mad people no
hair and clothes business strident and
we checked on my father you know maybe
we are going to survive looked at people
running around maybe there are workers
my father said to me look my family said
I think we have arrived and there's one
thing I I want to tell you whoever
survives you've got to go and work right
away
sell your knowledge go to work keep your
sanity and keep the principles that you
have been taught
they did a train screeched all of a
sudden II they kill me they locked the
doors
and we had voices dogs barking and never
never people were jumping in and dogs
were jumping in with them and they were
screaming and yelling arouse around
surrounds you know and then you were
confused you knew there was nothing and
one guy walked in must have been a
prisoner sister says to me Nitish hast
the gold must've really young do I have
gold and do I have diamonds crazy or
something and then I saw people have
been thrown out of there and I saw all
the people they have to go and then and
then jump out of the into the train the
platform was low and the train was high
and people were beaten and then when he
walked out of there but finally got out
of the Train I know those of those
boxcars all of a sudden there was a
bench hit you you didn't know what that
is
and nobody told you what is going to
happen nobody told you where you are
what's going on the only thing that you
saw me saw SS and we saw prisoners and
striped clothes and I saw dogs who were
sniffling and I saw people being beaten
up and they tell you to stand on line
and then way in a distance you hear
music a band playing my god it was such
a confusion of you didn't know what was
going on I served this high as s you
know there from a distance is high SS
officer with the big German Shepherd
next to him and they the women had to
step in front of him one by one I saw a
brief exchange of words and a servant
pointing either to his right
to his left and when I looked a little
later I saw all the older people and
mothers and children or sick or
handicapped people were sent to his left
there also is Polish people both Jews
and non-jews helped because they would
say to these young women who carried
their babies on their arms give it to
your mother give it to your mother you
know don't be a fool you can save your
life and many things many many demanded
that the hand of the babies to the order
given and even to the working side and
they were saved their children perished
but the day we arrived in Auschwitz the
SS people came in the soldiers and we
were stark naked they were waiting to
have our head shaved and he recognized
that opera singer she was a Jewish woman
and he got very hysterical a smirk on
his face
and he made that woman a middle-aged
woman get up stark naked and sing
what would you know I've oh oh six nine
I still have it I'm not ashamed of it
they should be ashamed of it this man
came the stall SS man and he pointed
with a finger he put my brothers
together and my little kid brother there
and I told my little brother I said to
him Sally
gay to talk to your mommy go with light
and like a little kid he followed he did
little did I know this did I send them
to to the crematorium I feel like I
killed it
my brother who lives now in New York
he's to live in South America the every
time you see each other he talks about
it and he says no I am responsible
because I said that same thing to you
and it's been bothering me too
I've been thinking whether he has
reached my mother and father and when he
did reach my mother and father he
probably told him it says of Lumia
bazooka Jesus gained in stocks or gains
with Ainge I wonder what my mother and
father was thinking especially when when
when they were all but they all went
into the air today to the crematorium I
can't get it out of my head it hurts me
it bothers me in Ana I don't know what
to do
[Music]
ouch wits if I would like to describe it
I would say that is there has not been
and that has not been people did not
invent an expression but I'm sure it was
it was hell on earth
and the silence of Auschwitz was hell
the nights were held and the days
somehow he we got up at three o clock in
the morning and at 4 o clock summer time
or 4:30 when the Sun came up it was not
like the Sun I swear to you it was not
bright
it was always read to me it was always
black to me it never said never never
was life to me it was destruction and in
the evening when you dare to go out and
you saw the flames of the crematorium
that was disastrous the smell of the
human flesh which we didn't know it was
very young kids inexperienced
of such horror who is my father my
brother and I were throw what taken in
one direction
my mother was immediately put into
another camp I was particularly attached
to my mother so it was devastating I
would say but interestingly enough as I
said to you there was a instinct sub
instinct of survival that quite frankly
I didn't dwell on it I can tell you
honestly I attribute my survival to this
instinct because I saw children just
falling by the wayside people dying as a
matter of fact I trained myself to be
very brutal very cold and oftentimes I I
have suddenly I guess I can't ask them
to turn this off Kenny no no keep it
running it should be documented I
sometimes think I was made to inhuman
because I didn't care about anybody else
there were all nationalities a lot of
people think that it was only the Jewish
people alone but there were political
prisoners and captured prisoners as such
as I was I was in the 11th Armored
Division 11th armored infantry and they
moved this to camp of Camp mathausen and
before I went to the quarry I worked and
I suppose you'd call it like a carpenter
shop where they were working with wood
but I was anxious to get out of there
because one of the men made a mistake
cutting a piece of wood and he tried to
hide it but he was seen in the officer
there was in charge there walked up and
he picked up the piece of wood and he
looked at it and he looked at this guy
you know and then he grabbed him by the
arm and when his I'm into the band saw
sort of hand over the corner push the
man gun off when he picked up his arm
he's trying to put his on back on and he
died Chris bled to death you know nobody
helped him just bled to death I don't
think that was ever a week that went by
when you didn't feel this maybe yet it
was one of those situations that you
always kept looking over your shoulder
you always have to think 10 steps ahead
you always had to plan what if what if
obviously you don't always keep your
head down trodden you try just to
survive you have to make light so there
would be times that I remember we would
make some jokes say try to lighten
things out for example when we were in
ambush involved I remember that my
brother and I began to sing to entertain
me
there were some poets and writers
amongst the Jews and they began writing
songs for us and we'd sing them and you
say how can you do this and listen this
Inferno how can you do this and all this
you have to find moments when I was in
the camp I managed to find a roll of
toilet paper and I didn't manage to also
buy bought her something I had put a
pencil and I started to write and I was
writing down everything that was
happening to me I was about my longings
my fears conversations I overheard
things people had said and at one point
this roll of toilet paper was found in
one of the searchers by the soldiers and
I remember coming back from their peril
seeing a soldier sitting on the lower
bunk from the one I was with the toilet
paper and rolling it and reading it to
someone else and nothing and finding it
very amusing when I suddenly had rushed
up to snapchat they pulled it away and
he said no this is too good for you and
he took it with him
and of course I heard the conversation I
heard what they were describing one of
the things that I remember him saying to
the other was she has a wonderful sense
of humor and I didn't remember writing
anything funny in it but I used to do
was I used to take the sulfur from a
pocketknife supported into the missile
in the each one of us had a quarter of
doing
and if you didn't do it you would be and
that's when that allows routes my
clothes flowers my lousy to be every
second every minute and we're driving
you are your mind and to top it all of
that Foreman come lunchtime you can come
in and have our sandwich a sick sandwich
in his hand with with all kinds of
saying you know Mel in general you know
you don't major in you are hungry anyhow
and he used to eat it in from them and
after he got through with it evil you
know you tried to you threw it down on
the floor so that we could all go in and
try and and grabber from on I remember
there the hunger that wrenching twisting
pain that he lived with you on a daily
basis all you could ever think of is to
get something to read you could never
fill your belly
it used to be uppermost in your mind
used to dream of a feast just one day
you kept hoping you could go through the
day without this twisting pain that you
constantly felt that is an indescribable
feeling one night I was so hungry
I couldn't sleep it was a very bad night
they were bringing in people for
destruction from to particular parts of
the country from benjaminson of it and
the screaming in the hollering was going
on in all three chimneys well lit up it
was like broad daylight I couldn't sleep
my roommate she saved a tiny tiny slice
of bread
and a piece of margarine for breakfast
and that particular night I stole that
piece of bread from her I never admitted
and she got up in the morning she was
swearing like a truck driver and I just
closed my ears not to listen to the
swearing that [__] did I still in all
together we went to work in the morning
and she didn't the whole day she didn't
forget that she lost her piece of bread
I never admitted that I took it they put
me in a block with 500 other women
somebody told me my mother's do you my
mother was taken a few days before I got
old so I went to see her you know my
mother was do so it's like I lost her
twice really but she was very lost she
was lost
she was very passive she was very lost
and you know they gave you one portion
of white and one portion of soup for the
day and I my mother became very skinny
she was very thin and she was they you
know lost it so I used to bring your
mind soup to her in mine and I just cut
off a little piece of blood and I said
to her you know somebody gave it to me
eat it and I used to give it to her gone
out because if she would say to me eat a
little bit I could eat I was very homely
but I felt that she needs it more than
you know I was younger she needs it more
than myself so I used to give it a soup
and run out because I didn't want to be
tempted that I should eat with her it
was within a matter of months that my
father became ill very high fever that
was one of the signs you just touched
someone
they were literally burning up and he
could not go to work and generally the
word was you've got to go to work
because if they find you in there
they had a sport if someone became sick
and they took him out and he said I'm
all right just I want to rest one day
they'd say well okay see if you can run
a straight line and what they did in his
case they took a bunch of people out and
they told him to run in a straight line
but they were firing bullets on either
side of that line so that if they
couldn't hold the line and that's what
happened with my father
there was a period of time that I walked
around I would say that was the first
year I just kept asking why and I
couldn't get the answer I remember I
walked by a spot and a guard hit me very
hard
after I recovered because he did put me
into a sort of semi-conscious state for
a few minutes I turn around I said he
doesn't know me I wasn't even thinking
of the fact that I was a child he
doesn't know me I don't know him why
does he have such a hatred for me those
things you still know at me the
brutality of killing there was a clean
way of killing there was a brutal way of
killing I could not understand the
brutality and this one American we kept
telling him be quiet you know quiet but
it was very insolent and he was given
the Germans a lot of talk about our
language and whatnot and he could speak
a few words of German and so I didn't
speak any German at the time so I didn't
really understand what was going on but
the Germans were talking among
themselves and pointing to him and
laughing and they took us to mathausen
and they staked him out they stripped
him and staked him out on the ground
just for our exams I was stretched and
his feet outstretched but they didn't
put any pressure on him or anything to
hurt him come night time of course went
to sleep and all of a sudden here's
screech screaming and yelling and
whatnot and we jumped up and we'd go
rushing out and it's dark and we're
bumping into each other and went over
and the lot of the Russians had been
there for like I say number of years and
they turned to cannibalism we didn't
realize it then but they had so bad he's
taunted his body that he died from the
effects it was bleeding to death
and nothing much we could do and this
way the Germans were laughing because
taking him out just left him available
they were like five or six girls who
were working the pool though but it
could actively domination you know the
wedding or the powder in today grenade
so they were every day searched from
head to toe naked and when they were
going into work and then they left work
but they were able to smuggle out some
of the Pulver how individually in the
mouth we were able to smuggle out some
of the powder the powder was in some
cleaner capsule very small capsules
which were put insert it into the
grenade so they they
and then we gave it to the man and we
blew up one for not knowing in Auschwitz
so I want you to know that it was only
camp in the concentration camp with
Germans surrounded with really the
impossible we did blow up we did blow up
one from a time when the Germans were
looking to the points of this trauma
tell you they were able to find the
shells and the soul it was from our
factory and they took the five girls or
the six girls were working in this
ammunition factory and they home didn't
I just never got it out of my mind was
so painful and a whole camp it much they
were hanging there for three days you
know when I talk about it I just did
such a pain when I was at the last end
of my time in the camp and I was too
sick and I was told not to go in sick
call and I asked why and they said you
don't come back from sick though
and I was pretty sick and so when the
Germans made the inspection after
everybody gone out to work and found me
there and they started beating on me and
I crawled out of the barracks and I
crawled underneath and underneath the
barracks results
Marcus flaming human feces and whatever
and I got down there they tried to chase
me off from under there that night when
I call out some of the followers of Lou
in my outfit they were still alive
brought me with some soup and the next
morning they found me with the dead
bodies and I stayed with the dead bodies
until nighttime they'd bring me back in
again at nighttime because they would
bury from one end the oldest bodies
first day they couldn't catch up with
the amount so they were you know
cremated so they put me with the fresh
bodies every morning that was one of the
first change we had to do was to carry
out the dead right across from us with a
charnel-house dealt with corpses not
just the inside but over salami no but
they were corpses all over I left walked
beside that people and after a while it
just got to be so that noticed and one
had to say to myself I'm not going to
see you like this
I'm not going to recognize anyone in
this person was lying there and it got
to the point where I realized that I had
to close my eyes to a number of things
otherwise I would not have survived even
at that time because I saw people around
me burning man I just not only having to
live with all these things but with
madness I was very sick I got the over
here that was already recuperating a
little bit from the malaria and I walked
out with two pails of human waste and I
was going towards the dump I walked out
in between the barracks
what a mountain of people I as high as
myself of course I wasn't those you know
the wouldn't she was the Hollanders
shoes and whatever the people died at
nights they were just taken out of I'm
the dump you know a big pile of people
and I said to myself Oh God
must I walk by but the new meanwhile I
couldn't hold back and I just put that
two pails and I said down because I had
a sick stomach and the rats were
standing and eating the people's faces
eating you know they were having a
anyway I had to do my job I was just
looking what's happening to a human
being it could have been my mother that
whatever my father definitely my sister
or my brother sometimes at night I lay
and I can't believe what my eyes had
seen I really cannot believe it you know
I wasn't in Auschwitz
whenever I got up in the morning the
lines were unbelievable and nobody used
to get up in the morning that's it my
love it how can God allow this to kids
were standing in line waiting to be
cremated
[Music]
word spread arrived that the Russian
troops are coming close from the east so
I don't hope they're on the rise again
because we thought the Germans will just
disappear around away and leave us there
to be liberated by the Russians but that
would have been too good a fateful I
still go to service instead on January
20th they lined us up again through each
of us a quarter of the dread inside the
Kim Oxley bear outside the camp lineup
and that's when the death march started
the March started it we didn't know then
later it became known as the death march
in the truest sense of the word
all the people everybody who couldn't
walk they just took and I said no I'm
not going I don't care
and what we stay still what we were made
believe that the whole camp is mind that
once the Germans will leave they will
blow up Auschwitz I didn't care I told
you after I saw this girl thing
something happened to me I really was
this was already I was so close to those
girls I just it was just very very very
terrible so this whole bedraggled group
was marching and people were dying left
and right
it was just it was absolutely and there
was nothing you could do I mean if you
try to help somebody you know you would
stay there hopeless you know as we
started to march into the woods must
have been late in the night when they
made us stop and lay down an ice
because I remember in the morning we'll
walk up no order our bodies melted the
ice the shoes we had gotten had wooden
soles and from working so much the sole
straw off completely
also when the snow fell the snow would
stick to the sole so you couldn't walk
with them either anyway they just
dissipated little shoes dissipated and
at that point we were to slip a piece of
cloth off our whatever we had and our
feet and we couldn't bend our knees or
the ankles just walk like robots just
drag step by step but we knew the minute
we fall down that was the end
my sister kept her saying she cannot do
it then I said you have it and it came
to one point if I had to take her on my
deck and practically carry her and those
who couldn't walk the German would say
once or twice gave the more skin a biter
but some of them they just resigned
themselves and they would march on about
thousand fifty five hundred of us and
then about five minutes later you would
hear a sound of a gun start at the ring
it was like a cloud burst
thunder lightning it was pouring and
they just kept shooting all night they
decimated us that night this was one of
the most unbelievable experience that
any man can even visualize then the
nature came back to life it's a March or
so and they started to sprout they would
run into the field and pick up the blade
of glass bat from the tree to eat to eat
to eat just to eat we left five or ten
thousand and by the time trip was over
the norm a few hundred I was left
[Music]
I was in my I guess mid 20s or late 20s
26 27 of them doubts at that time my
rank at that time was first lieutenant I
was an infantry officer in General
Patton's Third Army
we were waiting by we I'm referring to
my specific unit we were told to stop
and wait for the advance of the soviet
army that was coming from the east from
vienna that they had recently captured
and approaching us unfortunately nobody
counted that the russian forces would be
held up in vienna so the whole thing got
delayed and in the meantime one of the
streets was going on there was no food
in the camp and there were I mean what
sort of a concentration camp at its
worst there was in the camp was
overcrowded there were cases of
cannibalism in the camp at that time
there was a little bit of grass or some
stuff like that growing out said it was
only eaten there was nothing there I'll
never forget it there was a huge pile of
corpses each pile of corpses it's been
moving they were still alive and
breathing but they were just piled up
then this pile was actually moving this
whole time you know the moment somebody
sort of a fainted or passed out you know
you just simply used to dragon and put
them on there two or three tanks then he
stumbled upon Mauthausen concentration
camp again there was no prior knowledge
as far as we knew to the existence of
this major concentration camp the the
the effect I think was pure chance that
our American tanks
town names I jumped out of the Jeep to
head in towards the main gate and even
though it was a beautiful day very very
beautiful day as I mentioned I felt the
brief chill I don't know what caused the
chill
perhaps a premonition of what we were
about to see what then the camp but I
jump down to the Jeep and then proceeded
into the camp looking around at this
horrifying picture of stone barbed wire
machine guns that encircled the whole
camp we heard some commotion all over my
stamina Mendez pressure all over the the
gates were closed and I want to
emphasize that sans widows did not have
only Jewish prisoners they have been
busy lots of Danish and Dutch prisoners
and gypsies and the gates were closed
and everybody was standing in the yard
like one man and about eleven o'clock we
heard a tank stopping at the gate and
two shots fired and the gates opened and
as we ran there was a white and black
America
standing side-by-side in the tank that's
the first time I saw a black I loved him
for my life and he stood that erect
maybe because he understood and the boss
was running and he shot him
I still inseam lying there it was his
beautiful shiny boots that I was shining
in her before and I had no pity on him
I'm fairly buried and he said everybody
goes and everybody went crazy crazy
it was April eleventh four o'clock in
the afternoon I remembered as clear as a
bell
I remember the Americans coming in I
remember we almost killed one of them
because we kept throwing him up in the
air and you just couldn't take it his
body couldn't take it but the first
there was that is this really an
American soldier don't forget we heard
the front coming up you hear the
bombardment and you hear the heavy
cannon fire in the distance so we knew
they were coming and when you see the
skeleton crew you begin to realize
something is happening you walk around
you just sit yourself is this really
happening it's a it's a feeling that is
elation but at the same time you say
don't get carried away because it might
be a letdown so you don't know whether
you want to jump or whether you want to
be happy or not when they finally came
in and you saw the jeeps rolling you saw
the different uniforms you realized it's
over
the thing that impressed I think all of
us immediately was the horrible physical
condition of most of the inmates whom we
saw some of them actually looked almost
like living skeletons I took a look at
some and and I would estimate their
average weight might have been probably
85 90 pounds of so many inmates
including some whom I met later were in
very bad situations physically from
diseases there was diarrhea dysentery
typhoid pneumonia [__] there you have it
any almost any disease mentionable but
if the saddest thing in my life has been
that I have no recollection of the
liberation because I was totally Arabic
the typhus had I had to wait another two
days for the English I would not have
survived so they bring up these K
rations and they distributed that
throughout the camp now this produce
tremendous death rate instantly people
were eating that stuff and it got
diarrhea and there was nothing in the
world to stop it you know I mean was it
was like poison and I remember they were
doctors and Kant prisoners kept going
around saying don't eat this your bodies
can take I don't remember what I paid my
cheat but I know I overdid it
thank God I didn't die but I was
it's definitely sick we talked with some
of the civilians down in the camera and
they of course denied any knowledge
whatsoever the care what they in effect
was saying that up at the top of the
hill where the camp was that this to
them was just a training area for the
German troops in other words they were
trying to impress us with the fact that
that this was to them only a training
camp for German troop state admit if no
knowledge whatsoever or the
concentration camp and they just
basically lied to us
perhaps with few exceptions all the way
through because when one analyzes the
records of what had actually gone on at
that place the people could not help but
know that the camp was there and there
was this American soldier who spoke
polish any SS will be war
now we explained it to him he
interpreted to the American voice and
one of them took off a submachine gun he
handed it to me motioning to kill the
German prisoners anything very
frightened then I gave it back to him as
walked away from I couldn't believe it
that the Americans were real I couldn't
believe it that the Germans were
actually defeated it took a long time to
understand that there was a stronger
power in Germany to us they were the
all-powerful and they brainwashed us
brain washed us to such an extent that
we had no believe in ourselves we had no
understanding for right and wrong and I
recall the same afternoon I sat down on
a big stone and I said it was like
what's know what's going to happen to us
now we're all free I feel really free
what's the family
the young person where the sheltered
innocent life and what am I going to do
now it's going to take care of me after
the war we went back we didn't even want
to make to lay claim to anything we just
wanted to look for our families we want
to crack up and that two-week period we
were there there were two programs I
cannot find the words to describe the
feeling the incredulous Ness
it's impossible to elucidate here I'm
coming back from what I call hell and I
remember saying to myself you know when
we get back to call they're gonna feel
sorry for us they look from the door
swings and we arrive in krakow and
waiting in one of those holding areas
for the DPS and they're attacking with
non guns knives it was time the Russians
were protecting us I heard a group of
Polish people talking amongst themselves
saying something to the effect
well whatever Hitler did at least were
grateful to him for having solved the
Jewish problem for us now this is after
the war this is after what has happened
to our people what I felt when the
liberation came
the time alone in the whole world I
escaped from the transport Ivan I run
away two weeks before two and a half
weeks before the liberation I wanna win
she hustled back yet I had no desire to
live I had no place to go I had nobody
to talk to I would just simply lost
without words
[Music]
we arrived in June was June the 27th I
recall and the June the 29th a group of
children were going to a camp and my
uncle said we're going to central Turkey
and we said nothing doing no this is a
good camp nothing doing nothing doing we
wouldn't go one of the things I remember
as a child coming out I felt I had to
tell the world what was happening that
was that was a highest priority so I
remember the first few months in the
yeshiva
I would speak freely I would tell kids
everything I would tell my rabbi what
happened and so on then one day we went
out on recess and the one of the kids
got a hold of me we were all in a circle
and he said why don't you tell one of
your [__] stories and from that day
on this was 1946-47 I did not say a word
I would say till about five seven years
ago when I came to the United States I
was determined to tell everybody about
my experience inside was shameless
telling everybody in my family and I'm
afraid that they were not being very
religious people they felt that I had to
move my own experience into the general
experience of the Jewish people and I
found that it was a way in which they
were telling me they couldn't be after
this they discussed the the German
behavior taught us the tortures days and
nights it's something that we have so
it's now online you can't forget that
six million people is just
woman and children I can tell you and
everything in an interview I couldn't
even tell you describe one day in the
ghetto I don't want to live with that
pain but it's there it's there it formed
its own entity in its surface whenever
it wants to I go on a train and I will
cry I will read something and I'll be
right back there where I came from and I
can't erase it I'm not asking for it it
comes by itself it has formulated
something in me I'm a scarred human
being among human beings I like to
believe as a person who has learned to
think at a later life and as a person
who is a native German that the Germans
would not have been able to do all the
the total madness with the destruction
of Jews and other nationalities if it
had not been sort of tied up in this in
this madness of the war I am a product
of that culture and I think many of the
things that were brought out in its most
negative one were I was part of that and
I just really felt I had to get away
from that in order to look at myself I
couldn't do that in Germany I couldn't
do that asking these questions and how
who am i if this is German and these are
Germans and I'm German and I like that
am i that
I have given a great deal of thought how
I should I should conduct myself with
the Germans how I should feel should I
hate them should I despite them should I
go out with a banner and say do
something against them I don't know I
never found the answer and my own soul
and I have to go according to my own
conscience I cannot conduct myself at my
husband thousand of my children about
the world has said man the only thing I
can say is that up until I ignored them
I don't hate them I can't hit I feel I
would waste a lot of time in my life but
sometimes I wish my darkest hours then
they would feel what we feel sometimes
when you're uprooted and bring up
children I'm talking about the mother
and the wife and there is nobody to
share your sorrow are you great
happiness I see it personally is the
greatest treasure of my life that you
know they're Jewish people were deported
order on me I didn't do anything
I panicked not even panic not even fear
I just didn't know what to do I don't
know I don't know if it was worth it I
don't know if it was voided because to
fight you know but I was in
concentration camp and even after I said
to myself you know after the war people
who learn they will know they will even
see you know the land but did we really
learn anything I don't know
[Music]
you